I want to say something else we've
talked about this subject because
another thing that you talk about which
is likability I know that you sometimes
I really love it when you break into
song sure uh
sure well don't say sure that means no
this is good it's a good way to show
your listening is to say little things
while someone's talking well how do we
know that we're not just dropping those
in them
you know what I would love to do is
record John doing little things like yes
of course yes and then drop those into
other people of course uh anyway I would
do a thing sometimes uh over the years
in front of the writers where
I couldn't say something
um to them about how I didn't like a
sketch or what the flaw in the sketch
was but I could start singing a song and
the song would very specifically it
would be a very chipper song but it was
a very the lyrics were improvised and it
would then very specifically get into
what was wrong with the sketch and it
was like a spoonful of sugar musical
passive aggressive it's incredibly
passive aggressive but the song would
keep going and I would commit to it 100
and people would be chanting along and
then realize that they had just had some
I there was some lead in that dress
there was some I don't know what that is
but you're born in the USA
it was you were born in the U.S yes
behind that driving beat Reagan said oh
well you know well well we'll use that
as my song and then he hadn't listened
to the lyrics and I hadn't listened no
yeah they were critiquing his sketch yes
[Laughter]
I really like that and I love the whole
idea of being able to communicate
Truth by just singing a song about what
a waste of time Webster Hubble reference
was and how we won't recover wow we
won't recover you know what I mean and
then it's just it comes out that way in
song I'm the guy who makes references
all the time but when Melanie makes
references
I mean it's ridiculous
uh yeah exactly just like that you can
edit right I won't but I can no okay and
right where I did and then put in cheers
and then edit out the part where Melanie
comes right back at me and it's like
Edith Bunker saying maybe you're the
Meathead no and the problem goes crazy
edit in that time multiple times you
referenced to Tova Borgnine
yeah they had a bad divorce did they
Tova and Ernest yeah right he divorced
her because her forearms were bigger
wow add more laughter there I can't do
it and then uh some silence and then uh
music and then more left okay or was
Ernest Borgnine divorce from Shelley
Winters maybe I'm Shelly Winters he
stayed married to Tony okay great were
they married didn't they do uh Poseidon
Adventure together with Shelly Winters
whom I think Debbie Reynolds sorry no
Shelley Winters is in Poseidon that's
what I'm thinking were they married at
the time is Ernie in that isn't he
Ernest Borgnine is in that okay he plays
yeah Ernest Borgnine is let's go I doubt
it's after that actually no joke I think
I remember seeing the Poseidon Adventure
I think they were married in it
and I think he's like a retired police
detective or police captain okay I
believe you're welcome nicely done
nicely done yeah Sona finally made a
reference that I get all right um okay
okay let's just take it easy and
everyone just relax let's put the knives
away absolutely okay yeah your attack on
me I think was completely
you know my life has changed so much
Sona has it yeah let me tell you how I
can just get all this stuff delivered
right to my door I mean if you grew up
when I did in the early 1920s that was
unheard of you know a kid in a cap you
had to hey boy boy you know and you'd
have to say yes sir and you'd have to
say you know toss him a coin go get me
that goose in the window and hit say yes
sir Mr Scrooge but it was that was was
like back then yeah but now it's not so
much of our world digitized an automated
why stick to Old School mailing and
shipping if you mail or ship often let
stamps.com do the hard part for you
simply print Postage and shipping labels
right from your home or office it's
ready to go in minutes no long lines are
complicated setup required it's the
easiest so it's the best yeah postage
rates just increased again hello
luckilystamps.com has the best discounts
in the industry avoid the hassle and get
started with stamps.com today sign up at
stamps.com Conan for a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage on a free digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com Conan but you talk
about likability that's something I
think about sometimes clearly sometimes
it's funny because people that it
I clearly on the podcasts have shed my
concern for likability but yes you have
yeah but I'm saying I I I I'm in a good
way you have yeah I've shown how mean
you can be oh please I don't think mean
I think bravely honest is the way I
would call it uh no in a it's like
you're you're a monster you changed up
pitches and you're like oh the whole
time he's been mean yeah well we could
which is the which is the big reveal for
every comedian oh they have contempt for
so many people and so many things
oh that's the big do you know did you
guess what that's our everyone's Rosebud
is a sled that says kind of mean yes
I I don't take a second yeah
to think about the sled
just to collect yourself
I'm really rattled yeah you're shaking
up a lot yeah this has been a huge
Revelation for me how about that funny
waiter we had at dinner a few months ago
which waiter I don't even know I don't
even look at it remember how funny that
waiter was he gave us he gave you the
bill you nicely treated me to dinner and
he said
um and you said and I'm not leaving a
tip and he said sir I'm expecting
something absolutely amazing
yes he had perfect timing yeah he was
great he was very good I forgot I forgot
we had a good time didn't we did we see
any famous people that we saw John
Mellencamp from a distance I didn't see
him he was blocked I saw him I saw his
profile
we saw and we knew the guy he was with
that's right we did I had a I had a
um large gum abscess worked on that day
so my face had like a golf ball in it
you people in the restaurant thought I
had struck you I know it really did look
it did look my face
didn't hurt and I didn't want to cancel
dinner because he's so hard to get to
nail down plans with because ever since
he got married yeah
when I knew him three Liza it was like
we were like you know uh oh the times we
had oh yeah we were like Schneider and
uh and uh Kibler yeah yeah uh we're like
BBS we were like those guys no we were
they used to call seriously they used to
call us the wolf pack oh right and two
of you well there was another I don't
know if they want to mention the we
should mention the name on Mike it's
your call more than mine you go you say
it no I know come on we know it's toga
board game it is not
but it was you me Alex Trebek who's not
around anymore he's not around anymore
yeah well he's not he's that's a good
way to say it well I'm sorry he's not we
were young we were had we had fun we had
so much fun I tore it up and there are
whole areas of New York I can't go to
anymore right we'd close out Jones on
third yeah
it's a lunch place
people around the world that's a calm
lunch place it's really chill it's just
Southern California nice it's lovely no
whatever but then yes I got married and
I settled down and then you got all you
were like a baby about the whole thing I
stomped my feet at the wedding he did
he did it full-on Rumpelstiltskin he was
going up and down jumping up jumping up
and down stop me in dirty cowboy boots
a little Cloud raised up yeah but um
when you realize that I had this mean
streak did it endure you to me or were
you disgusted no I knew the first
there's also the only two choices uh
endeared me to you but when I would do
stand up on late night I got to meet you
like after I got to meet you on the show
and then I got to talk to you after and
you were talking about you were
on the other guests to me I was thrilled
yeah you know you said it was like
wrestling a cat trying to get an
interview out of someone and I love to
know that you had great contempt for
your other guests oh yes no I I think uh
it's almost you'd need to be lobotomized
to
to interview people every single night
and just be delighted by everybody it's
not possible now and you were you were
but also I knew I could talk to you yes
immediately that that was quite an honor
to me is that you felt you could
um you could say nasty things about
other people to me which you could and
you can yeah that's sweet that's really
sweet it's one of the greatest gifts you
can give a young man that you're
mentoring is to let him know how small
you are on the inside what a little yeah
little prick you are yeah what a nosy
neighbor gossip
do you have good neighbors do you have
nosy neighbors that Snoop I have nosy
neighbors that know that lies is a witch
oh because they've been hearing through
the hedges yeah
um uh I uh wait no but I love people
then there are people that are able to
you know our mutual friend who we both
adore Martin Short is
he's he's uh he can he's so mean he can
be so mean and incisively mean about
people and situations and gossipy but he
also has incorporated that into his on
stage oh my God and he's done it better
and no one's done it better and he's
he's so do you know what I mean he's
yeah I think aren't all comedians mean
sorry I mean there's always there seems
to be a mean streak in mean Mean meaning
um not cruel yeah if there's a joke how
would you describe it actually if you're
with a group of Comedians and they can
make a joke about you that's mean but
they'll know it it'll get a laugh
they'll they'll do they'll do it ten
times out of ten yeah yeah yeah right
yeah okay all right I was gonna say Nate
bargatzi once described doing stand-up
for people that don't know what stand-up
is he did it at a award thing for his
father and he said they don't know I'm a
comedian so it just seems like a mean
speech
remarks where you're on
products and people and the city you're
in and it really is that's all it is
it's just a mean speech so someone did a
uh
mashup online of all the times
Marty's come on The Late Night show and
he would always do the same thing you
know he'd come out and the first 10
minutes which was just delightful and
delicious for me was him
tearing into me with all these prepared
beautiful Jabs
uh and really going to town
and I would just be dissolving it's just
a pile of mush I was so happy and then
we'd we'd move on
and someone put together a mashup of all
the best Marty roasts of Conan and it's
online somewhere
and Marty who I hung out with recently
said that he went online because someone
told him it's really funny Marty you got
to check it out and it's had a lot of
clicks so he went online to look at it
and the first comment was
doesn't he know Conan could tear him
limp from him oh my God
four
it's like
what like Conan's just barely
restraining himself no it doesn't know
he could tear doesn't he know him he
could limp tear him limb from limb but
Conan's just showing great restraint
great grace yeah
everyone in the studio audience was
always going wow Conan is showing great
grace to this petty little man this
petty little elf is just
but Conan with his coiled steel muscle
keep it up short he'll be using your
hands
[Laughter]
I just I don't know it just was like oh
okay that's the essence of not
understanding I would like to make one
thing clear because we're talking about
how mean we are
I have to say it I don't I'm not mean to
anybody out in the world that I
encounter and I'm sorry we were all
holding like you're not mean to no no no
when I feel do we feel this is lost on
any I mean I don't know I don't know
because I'm gonna hear about it I'm
gonna hear like hey I so apparently
you're the worst guy that ever lived I'm
like now I'm back to your neighbors who
are you around that's gonna yell these
things
you always get the paper on the front
lawn I do yell things I do I go I go and
I walk out like Tony Soprano and I get
the paper yeah I'm always in the same
robe that Tony Soprano I bought it from
the Gandolfini estate hey More Travel
shows less interviews Conan yeah yeah
stick to what you're good at the travel
stuff is working
I like travel stuff
uh yeah I just want to see you want to
figure it out that I want to clear up
that you're a very nice uh fellow with a
that's nice for you to say I think it's
a Cold Black Heart we have such an
outlet for our uh uh anger and disdain
that most of the time we're very even
killing nice I'd say yes that's an
accurate statement I believe I would
absolutely agree I think I've been kind
to you when people were watching Sona
when people are looking I'm kind to you
no you're not you're okay all right
you're right you're right to her on this
show on the show you're brutal to me on
camera when you had your late night chat
occasionally I'll notice that we're in
public and I'll do some performative
nice thing if I think someone might see
it no I'm saying if I think people are
watching I'm good at replicating
kindness no isn't that a great thing
yeah